foreign new photos of Queen Elizabeth in
her final days as the United Kingdom's
longest reigning monarch this is a
family and in mourning now and of course
the queen was a mother a grandmother and
a great grandmother the queen Smiles
while attending an event at Balmoral
Castle the Scotland estate where she
later died at 96 years old
as the queen herself did with such
unswerving devotion
I too now solemnly pledge myself
throughout the remaining time God grants
me
to uphold the constitutional principles
at the heart of our nation other photos
show the queen just two days before her
death accepting the resignation of Boris
Johnson and appointing England's new
prime minister
Queen Elizabeth II was the rock on which
modern Britain was built
Britain is the great country it is today
because of her leading up to Monday's
funeral the public is paying their
respects in front of the Queen's coffin
I grew up in a household a royalist so
I'm here on their behalf and on behalf
of my family the line stretched over
five miles long with some waiting over
24 hours to get inside Westminster Hall
where mourners say goodbye to her
majesty it's a sad day but it's a day
for us to to remember you know the
incredible Legacy that she she she's
left meanwhile the Queen's family looked
to the Royal duties that lie ahead the
moment the Queen's heart stops beating
Charles becomes king he is proclaimed
King by the accession council that
happened as we saw within 24 hours of
the Queen's death but he may not be
crowned for several months I'm hearing
from my sources that it's likely to be
in the spring it gets very tricky when
when you try to break down the Royal
finances and work out exactly how much
they are worth well when you look at the
Main Financial picture for the royal
family the assets are land that the
assets are Regent Street and the most
expensive streets in the capital and
that land is divided between the duchy
of Lancaster which is the sovereign's
estate and the duchy of Cornwall which
has now been inherited by Prince William
what does it mean well essentially that
the royal family is very very wealthy
we're told by the palace that the issue
of titles is going to be something that
is going to be sorted out after the
official morning period and don't forget
the Royals have a further seven full
days of mourning after the funeral on
Monday
foreign